it's not easy pouring people for work
physically and mentally I don't think
people realize you need to then you know
there's a lot more like me do you think
huh forty years ago your FBI was founded
hunting down John Dillinger now we have
extreme violence between strangers we
travel around the country and teach FBI
techniques to cops you guys mind if I
bother you for a minute
she was found cuffed and lashed to the
bed what people won't do to each other
it's not some people want to do how can
we out we should be using every resource
we can talking to the smartest people we
find from the broadest possible spectrum
are criminals born or are they formed
Psychopaths they're convinced there's
nothing wrong with them so these men are
virtually impossible to study that you
have found a way in near perfect
laboratory conditions hello ladies
that's what makes this so exciting and
potentially so far-reaching I can't
think I rub off on me the way they view
sex women it is not our job to
commiserate with these people it is our
job to electrocute them I can't like
everything we do we're talking to serial
killers serial killers your terminology
I'm trying to warn you your attitude is
going to bite you in the ass so young to
be ruining people's lives how did you do
you're developing a pattern of behavior
that will not sustain you here
agent Ford if you leave I can't help you
there's no procedural rule book for how
to talk to these people if any of this
is going to work we need to talk to more
subs more you want truffle you got to
get in the dirt with the pigs
how do we get ahead of crazy if we don't
know how crazy things
[Music]
you